quel est ton nom garçon
hugo
hugo cabre
réalisateur primé à l'académie martin
you to scorsese
son premier film en 3d hugo est un
garçon vivant dans les murs d'une des
grandes gares de paris
et cette petite fille qu'il rencontre l'aide à
essayer de trouver un  famille donc tu es tout seul
pas complètement il y a
cet homme mécanique père il l'a
construit je pense qu'un magicien son
père qui est passé a laissé le mystère c'est
le plus compliqué que j'ai jamais vu
pouvons nous le réparer bien sûr nous pouvons le réparer
faire fonctionner cette chose ça va vouloir
dire quelque chose pourquoi ma clé rentrerait-elle dans
votre machine
voulez-vous avoir une aventure oui il y
avait un lien immédiat avec l'
histoire tous ces personnages essayaient
de se connecter les uns aux autres
les fins heureuses n'arrivent que dans les films
l'histoire n'est pas encore terminée
c'est quelque chose qui a toujours été
excitant pour moi j'ai toujours rêvé de
faire un film en 3d
l'histoire quelque chose de très émouvant
drôle parfois donne moi ton plus beau sourire
c'était comme une fête
expérience la magie d'hugo hugo  la proie
a cherché si fort pour trouver un
message secret de son père c'est tout ce qu'il me
reste et mon message
a laissé son chemin
jusqu'au bout